après ce que le conseil de place de ce
bouffon maxime gagné dans l'émission
dans tpm paix ça donne ça regardez c'est
parti
si vous n'en voulez pas plus du lac ait
fait ça
[Musique]
inspecteur denis pour vous servir
nagui l'animateur phare de france se
prépare une émission en direct c'est une
merde ça mais c'est sympa ça marche
package bateau plongée pas l'affluence
c'était la dernière fois que nous
faisons c'est trouverez et mentalement
je suis un peu en stand by
kelis et votre style bon pourquoi pas
salut tenter quelque chose maxine oui tu
es le nuage qui gâche rien
tu es la pluie étincelante qui élimine
mon coeur mais le cas n'est toujours pas
au nom d'allah c'est fini là là là là là
là bas je n'ai jamais compris une drogue
de ce pas ce qui ce mec c'est lâche
c'est la folie
[Musique]
est ce qui est triste et qui attend
tristan qu'est-ce qui va t'on pôle
emploi demain
si le gaming
on va démarrer doucement on va démarrer
caroline ithurbide qu'est ce que vous
pensez de bakhtine gagny très vite alors
maxime les points forts très gentil très
mignon bonne tête c'est très difficile
de vouloir te faire du mal en tout cas
un côté très attachant très
attendrissant 13 enfants portés pro des
travailleurs était drôle malgré toi le
problème c'est pas un peu les défauts de
qualité c'est à dire qu'à être trop pro
trop gentil etc
tu te caches derrière tes infos tu ne te
mouilles pas tu prends pas tellement je
trouve de parti pris et du coup tu
mériterais 2 bat encore très timide et
comme le prof tu adores et tu te dis
tous les jours cet été donc des jours où
je serais toi je me lâcherai un peu plus
j'enlèverai et si possible pas les excès
moscou ne rêverait d'état vie un peu
plus tranché que tu arrêtes de défendre
parfois la lord fonda bhl mais c'est
quand même les encouragements et j'aime
et j'ai mis un j'ai mis 6 à vous avez
changé la donne rien en l'état ce que
j'ai fait et c'était six mois je vais
très rapide 1 j'ai pas grand chose à
dire ni à redire au fait de son collègue
de besoin j'aime beaucoup maxime ses
points forts un havre de la magie s'ils
pouvaient temporairement faire
disparaître l'un des deux franchement sa
maman verrait déjà au bout de trois
minutes
mais honnêtement mon camarade beaucoup
de travail
[Rires]
j'ai la vision un million de fois à la
coupe rim ou faire non parce que je
regarde pas de ce côté là le point
faible c'est moi les scoops amouzou si
des fois viennent du chef lui-même ce
qui prouve que des ferries pigmentées le
chouchou mais mais c'est pas grave moi
je t'aime bien que tu es à + ciment
coûte ses courbes et sheila le cheylas
et donc maxime uribe s'est pas encore
complètement maxime génie mais
franchement moi j'aime bien à rome à la
sim c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut sortir
des proverbes toutes les 30 secondes
mais franchement tu es bon camarade je
t'aime bien mais l'instinct je t'aime
bien arrête les efforts de séduction ça
ne marche pas et laissez moi je te mets
s'atténue mais robert de la lune maillot
qui est le bradley cooper du pass dans
le lit cooper
tu as de bonnes manières et bien éduqué
s'est bien élevée matthieu delormeau
bien élever ses concurrents dans une
salle et que callejón tu dis bonjour
ah ouais là des conseils de gueule de la
bourgeoise nicolas tu es effectivement
pour moi un peu désuet un peu vintage un
peu jeune vieux mais moi ça me plaît
parce qu'au même mois
le style c'est ton style si tu veux et
pour moi être à la mode c'est quelque
chose se passe alors que le style sa
demeure au troisième troisième point
fort je trouve que tu t'affirmes de plus
en plus c'est à la fois magicien
imitateur tu prends des risques
t'as faim tu as un très très mauvais
point pour moi tu te tais les realities
un jour tu avec agathe un jour tu avec
toi c'est vrai avec carla un jour tu
avec daniel moitié
non moi je n'aime pas qu'on si tu veux
le privé on pyatt sur le public
d'accord alors la déraison j'ai eu une
très bonne note chassé par les
encouragements la gagne en force
matthieu delormeau a entraîné beaucoup
de bêtises attendez il est jaloux vous
avez pu lire dans un instant beaucoup de
choses a dit et gm canada et nous dire
dans l'instant ça se déroule m'envoient
des messages
tellement gentil que j'ai obligé de lui
répond la fois ya des coeurs des trucs
pas la tâche chaque fois comme quoi un
des plus beaux plus gros [ __ ] les
plus sympas du coup du coup tu dois être
sympa de timides s'acclimatant s'appelle
en déclinant autour de la table pour
égaliser en manager machin crime impuni
une bonne une bonne table et c'est vrai
que toi on dit à chaque fois on sait pas
encore exactement vraiment un personnage
on sait pas ton quotas âgées on hammami
ringard on agit n'est toutefois on sait
pas encore vraiment ce qu'on va faire de
toi et août m pour le moment route les
cafés abandon alors qu'est ce qui te
manque anglais pour grandir dans cette
émission déjà mon chou bouger savoir
danser
tejeda ce du corps sur ce que ce faire
le grand écart
si le dicton est vrai on baise comme on
danse donne pas d'avoir quatre conquêtes
pour le moment masque ou tes rêves de la
salle ben quoi ouais ouais ouais c'est
pas pour le conteur d'histoires d'amour
jeudi s'est jamais votre choix ah ouais
à la haine ou que sa note allait encore
pardon alors la note c'est trop long way
fallait bien trois et demi un
avertissement au canal bd oui alors je
vais commencer par les points forts tu
es gentil
voilà qui est un vrai qualité on va
passer au point faible donc tu as un
phrasé désuet employé un mot que tu
emploies ray qui est parfois ridicules
tescou moi je suis journaliste de
formation tu as quand même les scoops
des plus billon n'ai jamais entendu ça
dépend lesquels alors j'ai pas vu
bonjour et puis alors au niveau de la
drague avec kelly ces malaises tv en
permanence alors je t'avais mi5
ouais mais comme tu as tu fait bonjour
en veut alors moi c'est ma première donc
j'ai essayé de sympa parce que vont se
connaît pas vraiment et c'est pas un
micro quand même mais j'ai regardé quand
même les émissions alors ce que je
trouve c'est un sourire qui est super
sympa et ça peut faire passer un petit
peu tes blagues les plus pourris du
monde au moins ya la musique et donc
c'est sympa et on passe par le sourire
par contre ce qui est désolant c'est
vraiment tu t'exprimes comme un noble en
faisant plein de fautes de français
ah ouais pour moi c'est juste désolant
tu peux pas un événement énormément ça
peut arriver dans le thé noir lui aussi
peut pas être noble et faire des fautes
de français c'est son hôtel à avec le
paquet soit et rien du tout apparemment
fait rien
[Rires]
pour moi pour l'instant maxime tu as ta
place dans tpm paix mais dans le public
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est un petit goût de maxime je vais
commencer par att qualité c'est vrai que
tu es vraiment sympa maintenant je passe
au défaut alors c'est vrai qu'on en a
parlé tu ne sais pas construire un
discours bien que l'un des principes de
l'homme français c'est de mettre des
mots les uns à la suite des autres mais
que à l'arrivée on comprenne que ça veut
dire quelque chose hein ça ne veut
jamais rien dire ce que je suis heureux
ce que tu racontes les scoops que tu as
ils sont vraiment pourri franchement je
peux pas être plus vraiment c'est on
n'apprend jamais jamais rien souvent on
l'a vu c'est marrant dénis dents sur le
bloc
bref on n'apprend rien ça c'est un vrai
problème et
et c'est vrai que tu ne sais pas choisir
ton quand c'est soit noir c'est soit
soit soit blanc soit et great au milieu
et richard nixon
intéressant donc s'élever et alors ce
qui m'énerve vraiment beaucoup et ça
pour le coup je suis content que tu as
un don au dessus de lui pour la
paraphrase comme toi arrête c'est
l'hôpital qui se fout de la charité là
nantes est acquis c'est que la vérité
alors et là alors c'est vrai que diantre
ma femme souvent tu prends la parole à
la fin allait redéfinir qu'elle a été
dit bon allez vite vite donc là n'ont
donc jamais l'air je te mets un
avertissement et je te mets 2 il prend
dans les pas si mal son amoureuse
alors mon max ou accidents alors que
beaucoup qui travaille j'ai peu cyril
oui bien sûr et je travaille beaucoup en
amont pour moi tu es un élève volontaire
tu es toujours aller coûte de tes
camarades et ça j'apprécie beaucoup
parce que l'interet c'est important eva
dit ouais tu veux être miss transports
c'est vrai que je voulais me dire hiver
de marquer sur coup commercial
imitations j'aime beaucoup le commerce
je vendais des chaussettes à des
commandements comme corps l'année
dernière les points faibles
tu devrais moins à prendre tes fiches
parker parce qu'après quand tu arrives à
l'antenne
je pense juste à réciter n'est pas assez
spontané trouve donc ça c'est à revoir
aussi ensuite
heureusement que je dois mettre une note
sur tes qualités professionnelles et pas
de drague sinon je te mettrai 0 sur 10
mais malgré ça ça veut dire que
l'allemagne est vite la jeune grec pas
je sais lui c'est différent mais c'est
un magma de l'année pourront plus aller
qu'il y allait vite et mon chien pour là
pour moi tu es parfait je te mets un 8
sur 10 dons
mais ce soir
la gueule de l'ormeau jean-michel pas
oui alors marc si je t'adore plus épais
trois principales qualités
c'est que tu es poli propre et ponctuel
cédé 3 p et comme était un peu pro de
route je trouve à peu vieille france et
3 p ça ne va très bien malheureusement
tu as tes défauts je crois que tu avais
été embauché pour ses qualités pour
apporter des scoops en a eu quatre
depuis septembre c'est plutôt bien sauf
que le problème c'est que ces séries qui
les avait donnés donc ça c'est un peu le
problème
je passe sur le côté et diction
consensuelle le plus gros défaut pour
moi c'est un peu le melon tant que l'on
s'y voit exactement
tu prend pour le roi de l'afrobeat qu'il
est aussi le tu penses que tu as toutes
les femmes à tes pieds des cas inhabitée
tu penses que la fillette est épié
l'ours donc pour moi tagro 2 o mais
comme vu comment tu t'es débrouillé avec
teddy un gros zozos avec un petit zizi
sert à rien comme toi je te mets un
[Applaudissements]
et
regardez la tâche des plus tôt ses
chéris et or combien c'est mi matinée
les mois maxime kenny je me dis je les
adore c'est celui qui fait pratiquement
le plus d'émissions
je suis heureux de la voir tous les
jours il est souriant il a de
l'autodérision il donne des secours de
merde mais c'est pas ça comme maxime
gainey je t'ai mis cet ennemi est mon
choix a gagné donc ses 17% d'infos pour
vous râteau 31% gratot ringardise 8,8
pour cent -enfin voix chelou voie celle
où je suis pas sûre de l'orthographe
n'est pas grave vous savez que
l'émission ne sais pas le leur taux
grâce c'est parce qu au gabon
merci les chéris la note des tweetos
aller tout aux salles et les
chroniqueurs donc la moyenne ça fait
merci à ma retraite les plus riches en
actifs dégâts non mais là dessus en
régie il se range 13,64 ya les futures
alors 7,7
est-ce qu'on peut la boire ou pas 25'
rue deux n'ont pas la presse que voilà
six ans
cet ennemi ah oui td me bats comme les
sept merveilles du monde les sept nains
les 7-9 serait donc vous trouvé très bon
non non non j'ai mis neuf sinon
évidemment c'est énorme et voilà c'est
tout il ya des choses qui sont
perfectibles
comme disait jean cocteau ce que l'on te
reproche cultive le sétois
[Musique]
après concernant les scoop c'est vrai ça
les parties allez c'est bon mais alors
[Applaudissements]